Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a Malaysian comedy
film called “Beautiful World.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in an elementary school in
China where a doctor is weighing the students
for an annual weight checkup.
In the modern world, the beauty standard has
changed and fat people are considered more
beautiful and appealing than skinny ones.
The doctor praises a boy named Zhen Pang for
weighing the most out of everyone.
Zhen Pang also holds the record for being
the fattest one in their class for the past
five years.
The nurses set him as an example and ask the
others to eat with dedication and be as fat
as him.
After school, Zhen Pang’s mother comes to
pick him up.
The parents of other kids compliment his mother
for her and Zhen Pang’s outstanding weight.
One of the mothers is worried for her daughter,
Tiantian because she is too thin.
It turns out that no one wants to marry thin
people in this world.
However, Zhen Pang compliments Tiantian claiming
that she is thin and pretty.
He is unlike everyone else as he doesn't see
fat people as beautiful.
While returning home, Zhen Pang says that
he wants to lose weight because he cannot
even see his toes while standing up.
He thinks that being fat is ugly and dumb.
The kid insists that he would rather fly like
a bird than waddle around like a pig.
This makes his mother angry, who scolds him
for being unlike everyone else in the world.
One day at school, Zhen Pang sees some kids
bullying Tiantian, for being skinny and ugly.
He chases them away but Tiantian doesn’t
appreciate his kindness.
She believes that he is being sarcastic by
calling her pretty.
When Zhen Pang insists that she is beautiful,
Tiantian hits him and walks away.
Several years have passed since the incident.
The world hasn’t changed a bit as being
fat is still the beauty standard.
All the models on magazine covers, famous
actors, and singers are fat.
But Zhen Pang has grown up into a skinny adult
who owns a donut shop.
He is low on customers because his donuts
are not classified according to their calories
and are made of healthy fruits.
His mother is always worried about him and
the shop because Zhen Pang goes against societal
norms and doesn’t care if people think he
is thin.
She urges him to use more sugar in his donuts
but Zhen Pang is persistent about wanting
to make his products healthy.
Zhen Pang’s girlfriend Manco is also thin
and believes she is ugly.
She goes to “fattening classes” where
a lady teaches them to eat as unhealthy as
possible.
They are told that the heavier a woman is,
the more space she can take in a man’s heart.
Manco is distressed because she has only gained
0.5kgs in three months, unlike her classmates
who gained 30kgs.
To motivate her, the teacher reminds her of
the discrimination against thin people in
society.
She even gives a heartfelt speech on how she
wanted to harm herself because she was too
skinny.
After the class, Manco and her skinny friend
go to a restaurant and try to eat as much
as they can.
But halfway through the meal, Manco gets sick
and has to be taken to the hospital.
Zhen Pang comes to see her and assures her
she is pretty even though she is thin.
Manco’s day gets worse when the doctor advises
her to eat light foods for the next week.
After returning home, she complains about
not being able to gain weight.
Zhen Pang asks her to quit the fattening program
because it is making her sick but Manco flat
out refuses.
In their next fattening class, Manco and her
friend are kicked out of the program because
they give it a bad reputation.
The organizers do not want skinny girls to
represent them.
The girls retaliate but the teacher claims
there is no hope for them to gain weight and
become beautiful.
Manco and her friend walk outside the facility
in disappointment.
Her friend’s boyfriend has refused to marry
her unless she gains weight.
She jumps in front of a running car to commit
suicide when suddenly, a handsome fat man
stops the car with his bare hands and saves
her.
The man turns out to be the creator of the
fattening program, Simon.
He sends Manco’s friend home safely.
And even asks the lady who just kicked them
out, to enroll them back in the program.
According to him, the institution is made
for skinny women who want to feel beautiful.
Manco is visibly impressed by the boss’s
kindness.
When the two are alone, he apologizes to her
for the employee’s behavior.
Before leaving, he hands her his business
card, asking her to call him anytime.
Following that, Manco meets Zhen Pang but
ignores him completely and is too focused
on her phone.
Zhen Pang feels like her girlfriend will leave
him after gaining weight but Manco dismisses
the conversation.
The next day is a launch party of the fattening
program’s next products.
Manco’s classmates who have enrolled in
the program alongside her, are on the stage
showing their progress while Manco and her
friend are serving drinks to the guests.
Everyone is waiting for a superstar model
Debbie who is the honorary guest of the launch.
Manco approaches Simon and his friends and
hands him a special drink.
Simon introduces her to his friends as a new
talent who will surely gain weight in the
next three months.
But as soon as she leaves, we find out that
it was his idea to kick them out of the program.
When he realized the girls resorted to suicide,
he pretended to be on their side to avoid
a potential lawsuit.
The table makes fun of Manco’s weight calling
her a bamboo stick.
In the following scene, we are introduced
to superstar Debbie, who turns out to be Zhen
Pang’s former classmate Tiantian.
Because of her bullies, she made it her mission
to gain weight and be the prettiest version
of herself.
She is now a top Chinese model and hates Zhen
Pang for sarcastically calling her beautiful
when she was young.
She makes a grand entrance into the venue
leaving everyone in awe.
Zhen Pang, on the other hand, is backstage
delivering donuts for the party.
He decides to wait for Manco until the event
ends.
Inside, Debbie gives a heartfelt speech on
how she was bullied while in school.
After the event, Debbie leaves after telling
Simon that the donuts were awful.
Manco and her friend say goodbye to Simon
and the others but the group insists they
stay for a drink.
Manco agrees, not knowing that her boyfriend
is waiting for her outside.
As the conversation continues, it is evident
that Manco is jealous of the other fat girl
getting closer to Simon.
They place a bet on who can drink more alcohol.
Driven by jealousy, Manco drinks several glasses.
The men enjoy the competition and ask them
to eat the donuts as well.
When Manco starts getting nauseous, one of
Simon’s friends shoves a donut into her
throat.
Zhen Pang, who has just entered the venue
sees this and pushes the man away from his
girlfriend.
He gets into a fight with them and calls their
fattening program a scam.
Things get heated when he pushes Simon for
joking about the situation.
An angered Simon kicks both of them out of
the venue.
As they leave, the group makes fun of the
couple saying that they look like a pair of
chopsticks.
Zhen Pang takes Manco to a restaurant to calm
her down.
She is furious at him for ruining the only
good thing that was going on in her life.
She says that she has never found him attractive
and was in a relationship with him only because
he was skinny like her.
Before leaving, Manco declares that they have
broken up.
A sad Zhen Pang sluggishly makes his way outside
but a metal billboard advertising the fattening
program falls on him, knocking him out.
The impact causes Zhen Pang to go into a coma.
His mother, furious at everyone who led her
son to the hospital bed, decides to sue the
fattening company.
Soon, Simon and his employees get a letter
from her lawyer.
The media finds out about the news and criticizes
the company for making faulty billboards that
put common people’s lives in danger.
Since the billboard had Debbie’s picture
on it, she too gets backlash from the media
for supporting such brands.
She and her assistant look for a way to turn
the hate she is getting on social media and
find out the victim is her elementary school
bully, Zhen Pang.
The very next day, Debbie brings a bouquet
of flowers to the hospital.
She meets Zhen Pang’s mother and introduces
herself as Tiantian.
The woman is surprised to see the skinny little
girl from elementary school who has changed
into a beautiful fat woman.
Debbie compliments her figure and wins Zhen
Pang’s mother with her kindness.
She even transfers Zhen Pang to the VIP room
as an apology for endorsing the fattening
program.
But when she is alone with her assistant,
she reveals that she helped them only because
she wanted the media to portray her as a kind-hearted
celebrity.
Moreover, she wants Zhen Pang to gain consciousness
so she could take revenge for how he treated
her in school.
The next day, Debbie visits Zhen Pang early
in the morning.
She hits him in the face and jumps on top
of him to take her revenge.
But her plan fails when the impact brings
him back to consciousness.
Zhen Pang is shocked to see her but doesn’t
voice his surprise.
After he is discharged from the hospital,
Debbie starts visiting their donut shop every
day to meet his mother.
She also agrees to taste test the donuts until
they live up to her standard and offers to
be their brand ambassador.
Zhen Pang brings her to a private area and
asks her why she is being too nice to his
family when it is clear that she has always
hated him.
Debbie gets emotional and tells him how much
he affected her childhood.
As she yells at him to apologize, she falls
unconscious on the ground.
The doctor tells Zhen Pang that Debbie has
several health issues because of her size
but she refuses to lose weight.
If she continues to overeat, she will most
likely get heart disease and die at an early
age.
Zhen Pang feels bad for Debbie and wants to
help her, but he doesn’t know how.
Debbie is bothered by her losing 5 kgs in
a week.
She wants to get back to being 90kgs before
the shooting of her debut film starts.
For that, she brings out an illegal weight-increasing
medicine that the doctor has asked her to
stay away from.
Her assistant tries to warn her against it
but Debbie takes the medicine anyway.
As a side effect, she gets severe rashes in
her back.
The next day, she goes to a radio show to
talk to fans and motivate them to eat more.
Zhen Pang listens to the program and calls
them under the name donut.
He expresses his view on the trend and claims
that the size of your body should not determine
your worth in society.
He also shares that he used to be a fat kid
but now is skinny.
Knowing that it is him on the phone, Debbie
visits his shop later.
They get into a heated argument but Debbie
feels dizzy in the middle.
Zhen Pang brings her in and offers her a cup
of tea.
He calmly explains to her that her health
is more important than any kind of beauty
contest.
Before leaving, Debbie asks him if she can
really ignore people’s words and live life
how she wants to.
Zhen Pang says that he has been doing the
same his whole life.
Starting the next day, he meets her every
day and helps her eat less by eating all of
her food himself.
After the meal, the two talk about their love
lives.
Debbie understands Zhen Pang for the first
time and starts to like him.
One day, Zhen Pang’s mother informs him
that Debbie had to be rushed to the hospital
after she overdosed on fattening drugs.
Zhen Pang quickly rushes to her house and
finds out from her assistant that the news
was fake but it has affected Debbie’s reputation
harshly.
Later, he finds her crying alone and talks
to her.
Debbie expresses her feelings to him and feels
a lot lighter after talking.
At last, Zhen Pang carries her home on her
back.
A year passes after the incident.
Debbie took a break from modeling and worked
on improving her health.
She has turned skinny and way healthier than
she was a year ago.
Her assistant wants her to visit Zhen Pang
because it is evident that she misses him.
Debbie agrees and gets out of her apartment
for the first time in a year.
She goes to the park bench and sits alone.
To her surprise, Zhen Pang appears out of
nowhere sits beside her.
He doesn’t seem to recognize her at first
but then, hands her a donut and calls her
Tiantian.
Debbie is delighted that he recognized her
even after all this time.
The movie ends as they playfully fight by
the lake.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.